إذا كان قرارك في العام الجديد هو
ممارسة المزيد من التمارين ، فقد ترغب في وضع
نصب عينيك في سباق ماراثون ، يشير بحث جديد
إلى أن التدريب وتشغيل ماراثون
لأول مرة يمكن أن يعكس
بعض آثار شيخوخة الجسم ، دراسة
نشرت في مجلة The American
فحصت كلية أمراض القلب أكثر من
130 شخصًا ممن أكملوا للتو
ماراثونهم الأول ، وخضع المنافسون غير المدربين ولكن الأصحاء
لتدريب لمدة ستة أشهر
لبحوثي ماراثون لندن ،
ويقول الباحثون إن نتائجهم تظهر
التدريب وإكمال الماراثون حتى في
كثافة التمارين المنخفضة نسبيًا ، مما
يقلل من العمر المرتبط بالعمر.  تيبس
الشريان الرئيسي للجسم ويساعد على خفض
ضغط الدم يقول الباحثون إن أولئك الذين خضعوا للدراسة
لديهم انخفاض لمدة أربع سنوات في
عمر الأوعية الدموية ، تم
العثور على أكبر فائدة للمشاركين الذكور الأكبر سنًا
مع أوقات تشغيل أبطأ
للدقيقة الصحية اليوم أنا Mandy Gaither